tu
avec le 1er octobre écoliers collégiens
et lycéens ont pris ou repris le chemin
de l'école au milieu d'un optimisme plus
ou moins mitigés et jusqu'au dernier
moment certains ont pu encore craindre
ou espérer qu'on ne les prendrait pas
faute de place car dans ce domaine comme
dans l'autre la crise du logement sévit
il s'agit de cas 17 millions d'élèves le
sixième de la population française va à
l'école mais tout le monde sera acceptée
en se serrant un peu il est à côté des
anciens bâtiments et en attendant que
les nouveaux soit achevé on a ouvert des
écoles provisoire c'est ainsi que dans
paris plusieurs écoles ou lycées ont
maintenant une ou plusieurs annexes
de plus on a mis en place des classes
préfabriquées malgré l'accroissement
considérable des effectifs tous les
enfants iront à l'école et souhaitons
que les solutions provisoires ne soit
que provisoire
et
m